For some reason, I couldn't sleep, and
I
felt like it would be a waste if I slept. The
legs I saw look like this
[Music] It's
true.
You told me about the stars, right
? I'm a fool, but I
remember everything that the colors taught me.
The
book said that it was too dark to see it with the naked eye, but
I really couldn't
see it
.  I'll tell you, we'll
be able to find stars again From now on, we'll continue to fight together Ah, just now
I told Hiro that I was prepared to be arrogant, but
ah, we have to do our best together,
as leaders, the day is clear and the sky is clear
That's why I want you
to look not only at Jera 2, but
also at
me.
The stars that were attracted by the rushing formation and lewdness
Shined brightly just like us now
It seemed like a gentle light full of hope If you
make a wish on a shooting star, it will come true
What would you wish for if you were a strawberry?
Shun I just listed it
[music]